i think they're actually more
interconnected than you're giving it
credit for right which is
what is money money is time ultimately
right the the pursuit of
the acquisition of money right of
whether it's a currency or true money
is because that should give you more
time
and so one of my favorite movies ever is
uh and it's
funny because justin timberlake is in it
uh is this movie you lost
me i lose most people at that point
in time in time and basically the
premise of the movie is that uh everyone
has a clock that's embedded into their
arm and so uh if you go to work
you basically put your arm underneath
when you leave and there's time that's
deposited into your clock and if your
clock ever hits
all zeros you're dead you die on the
spot
and so there's a number of scenes where
people are basically running
you know to get to you and i give you a
little bit more time so that you can get
to work on monday and then you
work to acquire time and so basically
time becomes this currency
but what becomes very fascinating about
it is there are sections in society
where literally there's physical places
if you only have let's say
72 hours or less you're allowed to go to
section 1.
section 5 though is because you have
years and years and years
on your clock and in this movie everyone
at the age of 25
freezes from a biological aging
standpoint
so everyone stays the same but you may
have lived for a thousand years
and so what becomes so fascinating about
it is that
rich people have time poor people do not
have time
and so in it justin timberlake the main
character at one point
uh essentially acquires a bunch of time
and he's able to go
to uh one of the higher levels um and
now he's attending all these galas and
you know poker nights and all the stuff
and one of the first things that he
learns is that in
the lower end of society everyone is
running everywhere
at all times in the movie because time
is so finite and it is so scarce
and so therefore why would i walk down
the street i must run down the street
in the highest level of society no one
runs anywhere and in fact if you run
you are seen as lower class yeah
because wealth is time and so that movie
is you know it's got a ton
of kind of things that you can pull out
of it but to me is the perfect epitome
of
money is time and so when you start to
think about the
um acquisition of money right it goes to
this whole idea of time billionaire and
i know that
um there's probably a lot of people have
heard about this already but
if you think of a million seconds it's
about
uh 11 days a billion seconds is 31 years
and so if i said to somebody you have to
switch lives
with warren buffett would you do it
some people would say sure that'd be
their initial reaction i said but you
gotta have to be you know 92 years old
is the money worth the lack of time
most people would say no right there's
this guy graham duncan
who really articulated this well um and
ultimately what ends up happening is you
realize time is more valuable than the
money
but you you acquire the money to gain
more time
and the reason it's valuable is because
of the scarcity of time
we currently have the the biology
the physics means that um
this is not just the narrative we tell
ourselves maybe this
i don't know but it it feels like
pretty sure we're mortal and in that
sense the scarcity there
gives value to time it's fascinating to
think about all the thought experiments
here
of if that could actually be on the
economy if you can actually convert time
in a frictionless way to money well and
if you start to pull on this a little
bit and say okay
a young person today let's say somebody
in their 20s has about 2 billion seconds
left in their life
right kind of 60 years give or take
based on life expectancy
they usually until they start to
understand this concept
think of wealth in dollar terms
but dollars are being devalued and so
you know
a million dollars doesn't get you what
it used to get right it's kind of a
an old adage and so what you're doing is
you're pursuing
something that ends up losing value and
so it's
the constant rat race it's how do i
constantly try to get more how do i get
more dollars how do i get more dollars
because even if i say to myself you know
i'm gonna retire when i get a hundred
thousand dollars
when i get the hundred thousand dollars
the hundred thousand dollars five years
from now doesn't buy me what i thought
it did so now i need
500 000 or 200 000 or a million or
whatever the number is
and so ultimately what ends up occurring
is that
the bitcoin community and many people in
kind of this idea of sound money
is you want to be able to acquire an
asset
that not only will hold the value right
to store a value over time
but it will actually appreciate over
time
and so when you look at something like
bitcoin against the dollar against other
types of assets
all of these assets are down compared to
bitcoin right now some of that's just
in the early days of kind of the pricing
of an asset you go from very small to
something much larger
but now what you start to look at is
well if you have a finite supply of
something
what ends up happening is people begin
to value it more
and so in a world where dollars are
infinite
and other fiat currencies are infinite
bitcoin becomes
very very interesting very special uh
and something that is very aspirational
and so i think that's where you're
starting to see people say wait a second
this is something where that finite
secure store of value is essential
to wealth generation and preservation
over a long period of time
and if sam harris is right that free
will is an illusion this is really
interesting to think about
which uh maybe uh
time is the kind of blockchain because
you can't change anything
it's a uh so like and then the physical
space-time of the universe is a ledger
uh so maybe uh it won't be bitcoin that
replaces gold maybe it'll be
time once we crack open that in fact the
universe is
fully deterministic so maybe that's what
like eric weinstein is afraid of once
you figure out the theories
of everything of physics will be able to
then start
trading create a market out of like the
very fabric of reality
and that would break it well if you look
at
infinite inflationary type currencies
you can't do that
right because it constantly is losing
value right when you look at a finite
asset
again that has the provability of the
actual finite
element to it ultimately the wealth
is that marketplace yeah and so
you know i i always uh kind of try to
highlight for people
the top 55 percent of americans
understand something that the bottom 45
percent don't
they invest right the bottom 45 percent
consume
the top 55 percent invest and that's why
we have a wealth in a quality gap
and it continues to get wider and wider
and wider is because the people who are
holding the devaluing assets
and saving are watching their wealth be
devalued away and
there's arguments and controversy over
how fast that's happening but it's
happening
the people who are holding the assets
that have any level of scarcity right
real estate may not be finite
but it's scarce right art may not be
finite but it's
scarce gold may not be finite but it's
scarce
those assets continue to appreciate
against the devaluing currency
and so when you then say no i have
complete
finite supply with provability
and this transparency around it where
everyone knows how much is there
and what where it's going now all of a
sudden
you and i can transact back and forth
that value
and it is a representation of time
because what i can essentially do
is if i gather or acquire more of that
wealth
i then can apply leverage to my life
i can use machines humans
or some other resources and basically
now
free up my time yeah and it's not fun
about the way you are trading time maybe
it's a little bit indirect
but maybe not
you